Fox News contributor and former Hawaii
congresswoman tulsy gabber tulsy great
to see you first your reaction to this
move by the Secretary of State in Maine
they want Trump off the
ballot I think it's really important
Pete for every single American who's
seeing this news alert popping up to
recognize how dangerous this is you have
a Secretary of State who is a known
partisan who is known to be against
Trump she supported the impeachment of
trump single-handedly making this
decision to say the former president
cannot be on the ballot taking away our
right as voters in this country to
decide who we want to serve as our next
president and commanderin-chief you take
away the party labels you take away the
names of Trump versus Biden recognize
how dangerous this is where if this is
allowed to stand one person one person
gets to take away the voices and the
rights of every single American to
engage in our Democratic process that is
literally what is at stake here so
whether people like Trump or don't like
Trump or like Biden don't like Biden
that's not the point here if you're
democrat or republican now is the time
that we as Americans must stand up for
our Democratic process in this country
and our right and our voices de to
decide our
future PA see I remember months ago when
the when the rumors inside the political
you know chats and others were saying
well they might try to remove him from
the ballot in certain States and it felt
like no way they're going to pursue this
now they've tried state after state
after State they've succeeded in some
looks like Colorado may be walking back
but now Maine others are looking to try
it is this in the da DNA of the modern
Democrat Party I mean we're seeing it
through political persecution but if
they could would they remove him from
the ballot
altogether yes I have no doubt about
that this is the m Mo of the Democrat
Elite they will stop at nothing to try
to maintain their power even if it means
taking away the right to vote of
Americans so they have no issue taking
Trump off the ballot they have no issue
pursuing him and persecuting him through
a weaponized and politicized Department
of Justice they have no qualms about
doing whatever they feel is necessary to
hold on to power it's it's ridiculous
that we are having this conversation
here in the United States of America
when you and I have heard and we've seen
how how the warhawks in Washington they
will see this happen in another country
and they'll be very quick to say we must
go and intervene we must go and topple
this Banana Republic or this
dictatorship many of these very same
people are the people who are driving
this and it's not just Democrats they're
Republicans who are threatened by by
President Trump's unwillingness to buy
into their establishment
ways you know you mentioned that uh
eagerness to protect foreign Nations
great example you've talked about it a
lot is Ukraine we're very concerned
about their border yet you just heard
the numbers I reported about our own
what's the goal here blink's listening
to Mexico they're doing nothing numbers
are at record levels what's the goal of
Democrats you know it's hard to say Pete
I I feel like the Democrats and the
Biden Harris Administration are are
trying to put their head in the sand
here saying hey guys there's nothing to
see here you heard the uh the White
House Press Secret AR saying well these
are very normal normal things happening
at the border you have in that meeting
with with the leader of Mexico saying
well these are just irregular migrant
movements it is a complete denial of
what every American is seeing some more
than others depending on where you are
of what's happening in our country it
poses a direct threat to our national
security they have no idea who these
people are who are coming across the
border we do know that know that they're
coming from around the world we do know
that these are not just poor women and
children who are who are trying to
escape uh oppressive conditions this is
a very real direct threat to our
national security the Biden Harris
Administration is undermining our Safety
and Security and also undermining uh
leaders in this country their ability to
provide for the basic needs of Americans
we're seeing more and more cities saying
hey sorry guys we got to cut the budget
for things like education things like
sanitation picking up the trash and
sewage system things like Public Safety
funding our police police offic so they
can keep your community safe because
those funds have to go towards providing
for housing and shelter and food and
care for those who are breaking our laws
entering our country illegally and even
places like New York are saying no we
don't like the shelters you're giving us
you got to give us more uh a nicer a
nicer place to
stay yeah that's certainly how they look
at it would there would there be a place
I mean is there a place at all in the
modern Democrat Party for a view of
enforcing the Border or is it really the
way Minnesota's going which is any
illegal can get a driver's license the
way New York's going where non-citizens
can vote is this a electoral strategy
real quick amongst Democrats are they
importing
voters I think it's a valid question to
ask I think there are many Democrats
like myself across the country who are
disgusted with the democ the direction
the Democratic party has taken but who
are are are unlike me I left the party
they're afraid to speak up because they
see how the Democrat leaders will smear
destroy and try to cancel anyone who
doesn't go along with their
narrative P gabard you always uh set it
straight thank you very much for your
time hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else